petit quoi que ce soit
voilà nous interrompt pour nos
programmes pour suivre en direct le
discours de nicolas sarkozy à l'issue
d'un conseil européen extraordinaire
consacré à la situation en libye
nombre de pays d'afrique du nord
et du golfe
la conviction qui est la nôtre c'est
qu'il s'agit d'un mouvement historique
qu'il convient de saluer des peuples
arabes exigent à leur tour la démocratie
le progrès social et la croissance
économique
ce mouvement historique notre conviction
est qu'il ne s'arrêtera pas qu il
impactera l'ensemble des pays selon un
rite qui leur appartient de décider et
que l'europe qui partagent avec eux ces
pays une zone géographique la
méditerranée se doit des doublements à
la hauteur de l'événement d'abord parce
que les valeurs qui sont mises en avant
aujourd'hui par les peuples arabes sont
des valeurs que les nations européennes
ont fait leur il ya déjà bien longtemps
et deuxièmement parce que nous sommes
des voisins géographiques et nous sommes
donc au premier rang impacté est
concerné par la réussite de ces
révolutions arabes
et c'est ce qui avait fait que la france
a demandé la réunion de ce conseil
européen
indépendamment de ce contexte le conseil
européen s'est penché d'abord sur la
question libyenne
les décisions que nous avons prises sont
donc les suivantes le conseil européen
est unanime pour demander le départ du
colonel kadhafi et de ses séides le
conseil précisant qu' en aucun cas le
colonel kadhafi ne peut être reconnu
comme un interlocuteur du conseil
européen
c'est un point majeur qui fait
l'unanimité
monsieur kadhafi n'est pas un
interlocuteur pour l'europe
le conseil européen a décidé je cite les
mo de mémoire de saluer et d'encourager
le conseil national de transition basé à
benghazi qu'il considère désormais comme
un interlocuteur politique donc premier
temps du raisonnement
monsieur kadhafi n'est plus un
interlocuteur il doit partir deuxième
temps du raisonnement
le conseil national de transition basé à
benghazi est pour le conseil européen de
l'interlocuteur politique
son action est saluée et encouragée
alors que deviendra le conseil est ce
qu'il évoluera c'est aux libyens
naturellement dans des idées pas à nous
mais il était très important notamment
pour la france que soit reconnu le
statut d' interlocuteur politique à ce
conseil national de transition pour
éviter un risque entre guillemets de
somalisation c'est à dire d'un pays dont
on dirait le dirigeant actuel n'est plus
un interlocuteur
mais il n'ya plus l'interlocuteur donc
l'interlocuteur politique c'est le
conseil national de transition c'est la
deuxième décision troisième décision le
conseil décide que
l'union européenne permettra l'accès des
agences et des opérateurs humanitaires à
des zones humanitaires dont nous n'avons
pas précisé où elle serait pour traiter
la question des déplacés dans un premier
temps certainement en tunisie et en
egypte mais nous souhaitons qu assez
rapidement ces zones humanitaires
puissent exister en libye qu'elle soit
protégée pour gérer la question des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
déplacées et qu'il y ait dans ces zones
humanitaires des moyens sanitaires des
écoles de façon à pouvoir accueillir ces
populations déplacées
le conseil européen par ailleurs exprime
sa profonde inquiétude au sujet des
attaques y compris aériennes contre des
civils libyens non violent le conseil
européen pour protéger la population
civile en ses états membres examinera le
conseil et les le conseil examinera les
états membres examineront toutes les
options nécessaires pourvu qu'il y ait
un besoin démontrable d'une action une
claire base juridique
les nations unies et le soutien régional
je vous dire la ligue arabe c'est dans
le texte du conseil européen
le conseil européen a décidé sur
proposition de la france de proposer
l'organisation dans les prochaines
semaines très rapidement d'un sommet
tripartite ligue arabe union africaine
union européenne pour évoquer l'ensemble
de la situation et notamment pour parler
de la refondation nécessaire de l'union
pour la méditerranée le conseil européen
a également décidé la convocation sans
délai d'un conseil
giles délire d'un conseil des ministres
de l'intérieur pour concerter la
politique migratoire au niveau de
l'europe et renforcer les moyens de
frontex tu les ministres intérieur
européen devront d'ailleurs prendre
contact avec leurs homologues de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée pour voir
comment on peut organiser la maîtrise
des flux migratoires
d'un côté et de l'autre de la
méditerranée
voilà mesdames et messieurs j'en
terminerai en vous disant par ailleurs
le conseil européen a souhaité saluer
comme il se doit le très important
discours du roi du maroc
proposant une transformation
constitutionnelle de son pays pour faire
évoluer encore un peu plus loin le maroc
vers une monarchie constitutionnelle est
une démocratie
le conseil a tenu à saluer cette
démarche historique spontanée volontaire
comme étant particulièrement exemplaire
voilà mesdames et messieurs je ne mêle
pas lâcher le texte en anglais mais je
ne me mets pas le
textes en français complet puisque je
vais devoir retourner pour maintenant un
deuxième sommet que la france avait
demandé un sommet de la zone euro pour
parler de la gouvernance économique de
la zone euro
et je dois y retourner à 17h30
pesticides a bien sûr si vous aviez des
questions je me prêterait bien
volontiers ce président est ce que les
autres pays du conseil européen ont
décidé d'envoyer une représentation
diplomatique comme la france auprès du
conseil national de transition
il faut que je sois très précis parce
que ya eu des lions débat tout
vous comprenez bien que la situation est
mouvante dans un certain nombre de pays
notamment libye il a fallu harmoniser
les positions de 27 personnes tout le
monde considère que monsieur kadhafi
n'est plus un interlocuteur tout le
monde considère qu'il ne peut plus être
quelqu'un avec qui l on discute et tout
le monde considère que le conseil de
l'opposition le conseil national de
transition un par ailleurs est un
interlocuteur politique qui doit être
saluée et encouragée
alors cela veut dire que ceux qui veut
le reconnaître comme tel ce qu'a fait la
france
ce qu'a fait le parlement européen
puisque j'ai entendu président du
parlement européen qui a d'ailleurs
salué la france comme pays leaders pour
avoir reconnu l'opposition libyenne
d'autres pays considèrent qu on doit
discuter politiquement avec ce conseil
que c'est parfaitement nécessaire mais
préfère attendre un petit peu que sa
composition soit stabilisée mais pour
tous
l'expression c'est salué et encouragé ce
conseil et le considérer comme un
interlocuteur politique au monde pour
moi c'est très clair
c'est un interlocuteur politique c'est
avec eux qu'on discute et je crois que
dire de ce point de vue la décision
prise par lé parlement européen est sans
ambiguïté je joue
quel est notre choix monsieur le
président quel accueil a reçu la
proposition franco-britannique d'actions
ciblées purement défensives en libye en
cas d'utilisation d'armes chimiques ou
d'utilisation normales l'aviation du
colonel kadhafi contre les civils
je tiens à rappeler que même si c'est la
partie que je comprends qu'ils vous
intéresse la proposition
franco-britannique à ma connaissance
comportait six points vous n'en parlez
que d'un oui madame
bien sûr partir de chômage puisque la
proposition franco-britannique
consistait à dire le conseil de
transition c'est un interlocuteur
politique il faut des zones humanitaires
monsieur kadhafi doit partir il doit y
avoir un sommet tripartite mais s'était
l'ensemble bon alors sur cette question
il n'ya pas en europe
ceux qui sont partisans d'une d'une
option militaire et ceux qui sont
partisans une option politique
tout le monde est partisan d'une option
politique et diplomatique et j'avais eu
l'occasion moi-même au dépôt départ de
dire toutes mes réserves sur une action
de l'otan
et de souligner toute la complexité
d'une no fly zone sur un territoire
la libye qui est grosso modo grand comme
trois fois la france et les moyens que
ça mettait en oeuvre donc l'option
militaire massive comme l'a très bien
dit d'ailleurs le ministre d'état alain
juppé qui je tiens à rendre hommage pour
son déplacement en egypte et puis pour
la la réunion qu'il a tenue hier avec
les ministres des affaires étrangères
sur ce sujet donc la position de la
france n'a jamais été d'une option
militaire au sol d'une option militaire
de l'otan et a toujours été réservé sur
la no fly zone même si nous n'avons pas
décidé de fermer cette option
mais la question qui se pose eu un
certain nombre de pays dont les
britanniques et nous c'est qu'est-ce qui
se passe
si les populations pacifiques civile en
train de manifester sans violence et
pacifiques en sont la cible des quelques
avions de monsieur kadhafi
en l'occurrence les mig ou de quelques
hélicoptères qui tirent sur la foule et
la question que nous avons posée avec
monsieur cameron c'est à ce moment là
doit-on regarder les images ou doit-on
réagir et c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur juppé et moi même nous avons
parlé d'opérations possibles strictement
défensive ciblées sur quelques objectifs
militaires au cas où des populations
civiles sans défense se voyait massacrés
par une action militaire massive sur eux
alors nous avons posé un certain nombre
de conditions un mandat des nations
unies du conseil de sécurité
le soutien des partenaires nous visons
naturellement la ligue arabe est par
ailleurs les autorités libyennes que
nous reconnaissons comme des
interlocuteurs politiques et bien sûr
des agressions massives par des moyens
militaires sur des populations désarmées
et non violentes et civils
c'est dans ce cadre là que se pose la
question et nous sommes très satisfaits
monsieur cameron et moi que le texte du
conseil européen exprime sa profonde
inquiétude au sujet des attaques
aériennes et indique que pour protéger
la population civile
les états membres examineront je cite
toutes les options nécessaires et vous
comprenez bien que toutes les options
nécessaires examiné par les états
européens
dans ce cas ne sont pas que des options
diplomatiques en posant des verrous un
besoin démontrable ce que je vous
indiquais des avions de chasse militaire
qui frapperait une une foule de
manifestants sans défense
une claire base juridique une décision
des nations unies et le soutien régional
le soutien régional ce sont les
autorités politiques que nous
considérons en libye et la ligue arabe
l'ofj ces personnes ne le souhaite mais
il est clair que l'europe envoie un
signal et n'a pas voulu exclure cette
option
je crois qu en vous disant ça j'ai
résumé
l'état d'esprit du conseil où personne
n'est favorable à une option militaire
la personne de l'envisagent de façon
massive terrestre et lors de mon
entretien avec les autorités du conseil
national de transition libyen les nos
interlocuteurs politiques désormais peut
même en dit combien serait maladroit une
intervention étrangère que nous
n'envisageons nullement mais il ya un
mais c'est le cas de figure précis où
des attaques systématiques seraient
engagées contre des populations civiles
qui serait massacrés par des moyens
militaires dans david carretta de radio
radical une radio italienne est ce que
il ya le temps de poursuivre les voies
internationales dont les nations unies
la ligue arabe l'union africaine ou
est-ce que à votre avis un certain
moment il faudra prendre aussi une
décision européenne ou d'un certain
groupe de pays européens
pendant la délibération est clair il
faut leclerc base juridique pour
intervenir un mandat des nations unies
c'est nécessaire c'est préférable et
nous le souhaitons bon si y'a pas ce
mandat et ken demande régionale et
libyenne nous verrons à ce moment là
mais vous comprenez quand même que la
réunion du conseil européen
elle était très attendu en libye elle
est très regardé par les peuples les
différents peuples arabes
si nous avions décidé d'exclure toute
autre option aujourd'hui qu'elle signale
aurions nous envoyer ça veut pas dire
qu'on veut ça veut pas dire qu'on
souhaite enfin l'europe c'est le camp
voisin
nous avons la méditerranée en partage
les peuples arabes ont décidé de se
battre pour leur liberté et pour la
démocratie
notre devoir c'est de répondre à cette
aspiration
alors bien sûr le processus n'est pas
aboutie
notre conviction à nous français c'est
que ce processus impactera petit à petit
l'ensemble d'une manière ou d'une autre
l'ensemble des étapes de la région qu'on
est qu'au début d'un processus dont nul
ne sait dans quel sens ça va pas ça va
aller et comment ça pas terminée
néanmoins le conseil européen avec ses
décisions et en proposant à la demande
de la france
un sommet tripartite se comporte en
partenaire régional de premier plan
enfin souvenons nous dans d'autres
crises je pense à la bosnie ou d'autres
sujets vous même et vos confrères à
l'époque avait pointé du doigt l'absence
de réaction de l'europe sont son absence
totale alors que enfin plutôt son
suivisme dans certains cas alors même
qu'il s'agissait de notre région
mais je ne peux pas vous dire comment ça
va se terminer ou comment ça ça valait
mais la décision du conseil européen
sans remettre une décision de très
fortes
ça veut pas dire qu'à pas des
différences de sensibilité naturellement
résidents pardon une précision le mandat
de l'onu est il nécessaire où est-il
seulement préférable ça c'est le premier
point
deuxième point dans la mesure où toutes
les conditions vous avez évoquées sont
réunies est ce que la france et la
grande bretagne seraient disposés à
engager leurs seules forces militaires
dans ses actions très précise ou bien
demandera tel le concours d'autres
forces comme ça deux états unis par
exemple moi je ne souhaite pas aller
plus loin là dessus il ya trois
conditions des faits incontestables une
résolution des nations unies
le soutien régional nous verrons c'est
un cadre qui a été fixée je crois que ce
cadre et est satisfaisant qu'il envoie
un message à tous ceux qui doivent le
recevoir et permet de dire que l'europe
assume et prend ses responsabilités
qu'aurait-on dit si l'europe décidé
avant même d'y réfléchir de renoncer à
toutes les options voilà rien cadre qui
est fixé matin il faut faire vivre se
cabre dira bien d'autres événements les
choses ont très vite comme vous le savez
vous l'avez vu en tunisie vous l'avez vu
en egypte constate aujourd'hui en libye
c'est ce cadre et je veux m'en tenir à
ce cadre mais bon chacun me semble-t-il
a fait un pas l'un vers l'autre et et
les s'il y avait eu des malentendus ils
ont pu être être levé mais même sur la
je comprends d'ailleurs la sensibilité
d'un certain nombre de nos partenaires
européens des pays d'europe de l'est eux
mêmes en souvenir des processus de
transition d'ancien ministre associé aux
pouvoirs précédents ont joué un rôle au
début de la transition qui n'était pas
le rôle à la fin de la transition
et eux mêmes ce que je peux parfaitement
comprendre
quand il s'agit de discuter avec tel ou
tel qui a été un ministre de monsieur
kadhafi se disent est ce que c'est bon
interlocuteur ce n'est pas ben sur deux
ce n'est pas absurde de raisonner comme
cela mais nous leur avons fait valoir
que ces gens qui ont travaillé avec
monsieur kadhafi
aujourd'hui risquent leur vie avant ils
risquent leur vie c'est pas rien il
engage un processus démocratique
est ce que ces gens là seront à la fin
du processus démocratique
le libyen je n'en sais rien dire c'est
pas à moi d'en décider je ne suis pas
libyens mais risquent leur vie ces gens
sont sincères et quel autre choix avons
nous pour discuter avec qui donc vous
voyez c'est patent des problèmes
politiques c'est aussi les problèmes de
sensibilité
bon enfin si vous prenez d'autres
révolutions comme révolution des
oeillets au portugal avant d'être la
démocratie que nous connaissons il ya eu
des étapes
enfin pour ceux qui se sont intéressés à
cette révolution au portugal ça n'a pas
été tout de suite des démocrates absolue
des gens qui ont été dans les premières
équipes qui avaient collaboré avec la
dictature de monsieur saint lazare et je
pourrais prendre d'autres exemples vous
regardez en tunisie le premier ministre
actuel a été un proche de monsieur
bourguiba enfin comment faire autrement
je voudrais pas citer des pays oui voyez
la pologne va tous vous pouvez prendre
il n'y a pas un pays me semble-t-il dans
mes jeux surtout pas fait il n'y a pas
un pays me semble-t-il qui est passé
d'une situation de dictature une
situation de démocratie parfaite avec
des gens qui dans le cadre de la
démocratie tout d'un coup sont sortis de
nulle part alors qu'il n'avait exercé
aucune responsabilité avant je sais pas
si je me fais comprendre mais c'est ça
serait parfaitement impossible de dire
ah bon vous allez travailler avec
monsieur kadhafi
donc on peut pas travailler avec vous
s'ils prennent la responsabilité et
risquent leur vie
de créer un mouvement démocratique en
libye bien sûr qu'ils ont travaillé dans
le cadre d'un système comment pouvait-il
faire autrement
par ailleurs est ce qu'ils seront à
l'arrivée du processus démocratique dans
quelques mois dans quelques années nul
ne sait mais refusé par principe alors
même lorsqu'il fait que nous on les
considérait donc comme des
interlocuteurs politiques et non
crédible mais eux en libye serait vécu
comme des opposants suffisamment
crédible pour risquer leurs vies dit
points quelle situation
voilà le choix que que nous avons fait
et voilà la raison pour laquelle la
france
anne parlement des russie a décidé de de
reconnaître ces gens j'ajoute qu'il faut
les encourager
qu'est-ce qu'on veut les pousser à la
division qui est dans chaque ville un
nouveau conseil avant favoriserait qui à
ce moment là je crois que c'est sage de
faire comme cela
j'ajoute que j'ai trouvé des gens c'est
raisonnable en tout cas ceux avec qui
j'ai discuté le président du parlement
européen ne faisait là la même remarque
je sais que le président vandromme pas
il va les rencontrer et que madame
catherine ashton les a rencontrés aussi
le président sébastien maillard la croix
vous évoquez des transitions
démocratiques en cours dans la région et
notamment en tunisie en egypte et en
lieux de la situation est loin d'être
stable est-ce que là ce propos de la
réponse d'europe vous semble à la
hauteur soit base des discussions vous
avez pu avoir aujourd'hui ce document de
la commission européenne et du service
d'action extérieure je crois pour vous
répondre franchement je pense qu'on est
qu'au début d'un processus
qui va nous engager aller beaucoup plus
loin incontestablement mais qui nous
amène attendre aussi enfin à respecter
ces révolutions arabes
c'est à eux de conduire ces révolutions
et amener leurs processus et pas à nous
de définir ce dont ils ont besoin
lors ce qui est sûr c'est que nous
aurons l'occasion de refonder l'union
pour la méditerranée qui est plus
nécessaire que jamais il faut pour cela
que nous ayons phase d interlocuteur
avec qui nous puissions construire cette
relation j'ai voulu ne pas me précipiter
s'agissant d'un grand pays amis comme la
tunisie et s'agissant d'un autre très
grand pays ami comme l'égypte pourquoi à
ceux qui m'appelait à me précipiter dans
la conférence de reconstruction de la
tunisie qui avait été annoncé par le
premier ministre un outil qui a dû
démissionner à la suite d'un vaste
mouvement de foule comme étant des quant
à l'egypte le ministre d'état alain
juppé a fait un voyage très réussi la
barre le premier ministre david cameron
y avait été avant il y avait rencontré
un premier ministre égyptien qui a
changé deux jours après donc
certainement devra aller plus loin
réinventer un certain nombre de
mécanismes pour les aider mais attendons
que même stabilise un peu lent l'heureux
leur système démocratique
je pense que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle également que sur les la
gestion des flux migratoires nous
décidions des zones humanitaires en
afrique du nord pour gérer les
populations déplacées que nous ayons
décidé la réunion sans délais des
conseils des ministres européens de
l'intérieur pour poser une politique
européenne de l'immigration
la décision de rencontrer les ministres
de l'intérieur d' afrique du nord pour
gérer ceci ensemble car il va de soi que
y compris sur les politiques migratoires
il faudra tenir compte du fait que ces
pays devenant des démocraties le statut
de réfugié politique plus la même nature
je prends un exemple et nous nous à
cavan accueillis sur notre territoire
une grande partie des opposants
politiques de monsieur ben ali parce
qu'ils avaient un statut de réfugié
politique aujourd'hui la tunisie est une
démocratie
les choses ne se pose pas de la même
manière mais pour les étudiants va bien
falloir qu'on les a formés dans jeunesse
c'est donc tout l'ensemble qui dans les
mois qui viennent d'être amenés être
repensée sans doute réorganisé par dans
le parmentier journal le monde c'est
président petite question vous avez
parlé d' armes chimiques
ce matin est ce que vous avez des
éléments qui attestent d'un usage
probables ou possibles d'armes chimiques
par le bar monsieur kadhafi
deuxième question quand je vois ce qui
se passe comment il faut des faits
tangibles pour vous permettre
éventuellement d'intervenir donc qu'est
ce qui fait qu'on puisse intervenir
avant que l'irréparable ou qu'un crime
particulièrement gênant sur des civils
soient commis et troisième solution si
monsieur kadhafi
on gagne sur le terrain comment on sent
s'adresse la peine situation j'allais
dire à l'irakienne à l'ancienne tels des
fers lapsus amusant qui qui en dit long
sur votre tempérament et parler de
troisième solution
parfois il m'arrive de penser que
voudriez bien cette place et que vous
verriez bien là votre j'ai compris que
c'est des questions vous ne posiez donc
parfait bombe sur sur le l'opportunité
de frappes défensives et ciblées je me
suis exprimé
en détail je peux pas vous en dire plus
sur les caches imite je n'ai pas de ta
formation précise mais chacun sait que
monsieur kadhafi
d'ailleurs c'était à porter à son crédit
à l'époque à s'est séparé de son stock
d'armes nucléaires enfin dame tout cas
de réserve et de processus
à l'époque c'était d'ailleurs à porter à
son crédit je l'avais souligné moi même
le fait qu'il puisse y avoir ou pas des
armes chimiques je n'ai pas
d'information précise mais enfin disons
que certains des acteurs se pose la
question et on me dit mais qu'est ce qui
se passe il monsieur kadhafi l'emportent
mal justement c'est in
c'est une solution que nous
l'envisageons n'envisageons pas
politiquement puisque tournon n'est plus
un interlocuteur est justement tout ce
que nous faisons c'est cette nature à
encourager tous ces libyens qui veulent
une démocratie et et et qui doivent
pouvoir s'appuyer sur un soutien
politique et économique sans faille de
l'europe
on peut pas considérer que le fait que
monsieur kadhafi reste en place soit sur
autre chose qu une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'ensemble des pays de la
région
quel signal mais je voulais dit de la
même façon sans comparer les situations
en côte d'ivoire depuis le début la
france se bat pour que soit reconnu
l'élection validée par les nations unies
du président ouattara parce que c'est
pas que la côte d'ivoire dont il s'agit
c'est l'ensemble de l'afrique
pourquoi faire des élections si lorsque
l'on fait des élections le président élu
n'est pas le président en place et là il
ya une révolution que ces mises en place
des gens courageusement qu'ils nous
aussi on veut la démocratie on doit tout
faire pour les pour les aider
ce serait une catastrophe si c'était pas
le cas peut-être une dernière question
oui merci beaucoup
béatrice a déjà géré tête je voulais
savoir comme vous nous expliquer que
s'il ya un massacre vous aimeriez que
l'europe puisse anticiper dès maintenant
ce qu'elle est prête à faire vous vous
privilégiez des actions ciblées vous
nous l'avez dit alors est ce que c'est
une nouvelle vraiment que ça que vous
pensez qu a que ça qui est important
non là je vous le reproche pas mes
questions c'est normal moi je me
demandais c'était une nouvelle doctrine
diplomatique de la france c'est à dire
si en jordanie au yémen au koweit toutes
les manifestations contre les pouvoirs
en place tourne mal s'il ya des
répressions est ce que la france cette
année comme sa propre pelouse et moi
excusez moi le président moubarak est
parti ou été renversé à la suite de
manifestations de masse je n'ai jamais
vu
l'aviation égyptienne frapper les
manifestants il y a eu des brutalités
il y a eu des affrontements mais on est
resté dans le cadre de violences que je
qualifierais pardonnez l'expression de
civils un vin ce n'est sans doute pas la
bonne expression je m'en excuse auprès
de vous mais je veux dire que c'était
brutal
il ya eu de la brutalité il ya eu des
violences il ya eu des manifestantes
blessés sans doute y ait eu des morts
la fin ça n'a rien à voir avec des
moyens armés militaires aériens qu'on
envoie contre des gens qui manifestent
en tunisie il ya eu des manifestants il
ya eu des brutalités des morts mais le
président ben ali est parti
justement d'ailleurs en egypte comme en
tunisie parce que l'armée a refusé de
faire feu sur la foule
fin seul dans son immense majorité c'est
quand même bien ça qui s'est passé en
tunisie comme en egypte peut y avait pu
avoir cette tentation mais l'armée ad
non nous ne tirons pas sur la foule mais
ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé en libye
c'est que c'est quand même on peut pas
on peut pas dire que tout se ressemble
enfin pas dire que tout se vaut on peut
pas dire que toutes les situations sont
sans égal c'est pas parce que c'est
l'afrique du nord c'est pas parce que ce
sont des des populations arabes qui
veulent se libérer d'une forme de
dictature
mais c'est pas du tout la même la même
ce que je veux dire que les conditions
de la répression de la brutalité ne sont
pas du tout les même si en libye nous
nous trouvions avec une le chef de
l'armée libyenne où des dirigeants de
l'armée des militaires dont nous ne
tirons pas sur la foule en poney dans et
de cabillaud jamais personne n'a
envisagé de faire des actions militaires
ciblées défensive en tunisie ou en
égypte ça ne s'est même pas posée donc
c'est pas du tout inchangé excusez moi
mais je me suis sans doute mal exprimé
mais c'est pas du tout un changement
diplomatique que nous envisageons c'est
une adaptation une situation tout à fait
particulière qu'on a absolument pas
connu nulle part peut-être le seul
endroit où on a connu une mobilisation
d'un état state en iran dans les
conditions qu'on connaît encore une fois
et je n'ai pas vu à ce moment là l'armée
avant de l'aviation lancé pour ce qu'on
en sait donc il n'y a aucun changement
diplomatique
une nouvelle doctrine je suis opposée à
une intervention militaire d'ensemble
j'ai été je crois l'un des premiers à
dire ma réserves sur l'intervention de
l'otan qui est une organisation
militaire née entre eux refusé une
intervention militaire et laisser des
gens massacrés par des avions de chasse
alors qu'ils manifestent
il ya peut-être à réfléchir sur ce qu'on
fait si les nations unies sont d'accord
si la ligue arabe est d'accord si un
mandat
et si ces faits sont avérés on peut pas
me met enfin pardon mais mais je change
ment diplomatiquement venez vous pouvez
pas comparer ce qui se passe en libye
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé en
tunisie
vous pouvez le comparer politiquement si
vous voulez vous pouvez pas comparer la
répression n'a rien à voir il ya par
exemple ans où il ya des actes de guerre
en libye je ne pense pas que des actes
de guerre en egypte où des actes de
guerre en en tunisie il ya eu une
révolution politique avec des violences
naturellement mais là on est on est dans
des des villes bombardées des terminaux
pétroliers
bombardé enfin ça ne sert à rien à voir
dernière question que de jouer leur
torpeur
est ce qu'on peut
monsieur président puisque ça va se
terminer très tard est-ce qu'on peut
anticiper juste sur la réunion qui va
suivre maintenant par une question sur
la réunion qui va suivre maintenant
parce que ça va venir très tard après
donc je suis désolé pour votre nuit de
sommeil il n'y a pas de raison que vous
dormiez plus que moi dans ce cas la non
écoute et nomme un décès je veux surtout
pas désagréable avec vous mais je veux
pas mélanger des choses parce que j'ai
bien réfléchi à la situation qui nous
occupe en afrique du nord c'est
historique
donc je sais bien qu'on emploie le mot
historique à tout bout de champ et ça
méritait qu'on fasse un conseil européen
spécifique sur le sujet c'était pas
évident non de mes partenaires de ne le
pensez pas penser qu'une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères
suffisait j'ai dit ce que je pensais de
l'action de dans la jupe et qui nous
travaillons bien sûr main dans la main
mais je ne veux pas mélanger
l'importance des dix ans qu'on va
prendre tout à l'heure les 17 membres de
la zone euro
est ce qu'on vient de décider la ces
écoutes et tant de fois dans le passé
j'ai regretté que l'europe n'exprime pas
une voie politique un chemin politique
claire cas pas du moment où elle accepte
de le faire avec les citations les
ambiguïtés de que je reconnais bien
voter la situation n'est pas simple
c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
c'est l'europe qui est en première ligne
et c'est l'europe qui doit assumer ce
choix politique bien sûr il faut en
parler avec nos amis nos alliés
américains
naturellement mais nous sommes les
premiers comptes concernés c'est quand
même extraordinaire moins important ah
oui je vais m'en parler de cette
question là parce que c'est le sujet on
en a parlé pendant six heures je veux
pas parler d'autre chose même si le
gouvernement économique le pacte de
convergence
pensez être compétitivité c'est
absolument très important mais ce soir
alors tabac d'abord s'est mis d'accord
sur le principe tout humanitaire parce
que je le dis à nos compatriotes
si on veut que ces révolutions arabes ne
provoquent pas de peurs il faut que avec
franchise ne parlions de la question des
flux migratoires
il y à des populations déplacées peut
considérer qu'il y à quoi deux cent
mille personnes 200 milles je ne parle
pas immigré deux cent mille personnes
déplacées entre la lybie canton l'egypte
la libye la tunisie
si on ne traite pas l'accueil de ces
personnes déplacées dans des conditions
humaines et décentes quelle va être la
tentation de ces personnes déplacées
tentation n'ont pas le choix c'est à
verser la méditerranée nous ne pouvons
pas les accueillir dans ces conditions
là donc il faut organiser des zones
humanitaires dans notre esprit
ces zones devraient être gérées par les
nations unies alors est ce que c'est le
hr l'office des migrations je me sais
mais par les nations unies
l'europe devrait bien sûr participer à
son financement à son organisation ce
qui est la seule façon de gérer
tranquillement la question des flux
migratoires
puis les concerts les ministres de
l'intérieur européens et d'afrique du
nord vont se réunir pour voir ce dont
ils ont besoin
mais naturellement la politique
migratoire doit évoluer et doit être
maîtrisée des deux côtés nous
vont continuer à accueillir leurs
étudiants les hommes d'affaires et ils
doivent accepter de donner des laissez
passer consulaires pour les immigrés en
situation irrégulière qui n'ont pas de
papiers qui ont vocation à retourner
dans leur pays
donc on va essayer de gérer ensemble
profitons de cette crise pour poser les
bases non seulement d'une politique
d'immigration européenne mais d'une
politique d'immigration concernés entre
pays de départ et pays d'arrivée voilà
et donc les nations unies me semblerait
la meilleure façon et avec ça on peut
gérer ces flux migratoires
sinon on n'aura quoi la multiplication
de lampedusa et personne ne peut le
souhaiter personnes dont il faut
organiser des zones humanitaires
décentes avec des écoles pour les
enfants avec des moyens sanitaires de
manière à maîtriser cela et pour moi les
nations unies c'est mieux ça même alors
sa peau il y aura d'autres questions qui
protègent ces zones humanitaires
j'imagine que vous avez ça la france
peut avoir des propositions à faire et
en fera sans doute mais dans le cadre de
ce conseil européen je préfère qu'on
s'en tienne aux principes et après step
by step et à pas étape on construira ce
projet pourquoi pas tout résoudre
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup à tout à
l'heure donc
voilà pour cette conférence de presse de
nicolas sarkozy que vous avez pu suivre
en direct sur public sénat une
conférence de presse qui a eu lieu à
l'issue d'un conseil européen
extraordinaire consacrée à la libye
et pour commenter cette conférence de
presse michael szames esma rejoint bon
sens michael nous allons revenir avec
vous sur les points clés de ce conseil
européen et pour commencer que peut-on
retenir des annonces de nicolas sarkozy
la principale en tout cas c'est que le
colonel kadhafi aujourd'hui n'est plus
un interlocuteur pour l'union européenne
et peut-être aussi pour les nations
unies mais en ce qui concerne le conseil
européen qui viennent se tenir à
l'instant le colonel kadhafi n'est plus
un interlocuteur aujourd'hui
l'interlocuteur privilégié pour la libye
c'est le conseil national de transition
que nicolas sarkozy a reçu hier à paris
et qui sera désormais le seul
interlocuteur possible pour l'union
européenne et pour les autres acteurs
mondiaux c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne demande tout
simplement au colonel kadhafi de se
retirer de ce de démissionner pour
laisser place à ce fameux conseil
national de transition c'est une chose
très importante car jusque là le colonel
kadhafi était encore possiblement un
interlocuteur
aujourd'hui l'union européenne le
précise très fermement il doit
démissionner alors autre point important
de cette conférence de presse nicolas
sarkozy avait proposé ce matin la
création de zones humanitaires en
afrique du nord
qu'en est il et c'est très important
c'est un plan très important pour
l'union européenne car on parle de la 2d
flux migratoires il y a pratiquement 200
mille personnes ce qui concerne la
tunisie l'égypte et aujourd'hui la libye
200 mille personnes qui pourrait émigrer
vers l'union européenne et nicolas
sarkozy l'a répété il y à quelques
instants il ne veut pas de la
multiplication de lampedusa l'on paie 12
est une petite île près de l'italie où
on accueille quasiment toute la misère
du monde
ou en tout cas tous ceux qui n'ont plus
de papier qui aujourd'hui veulent
rentrer sur le territoire européen
ils décident tous de partir sur cette
petite île et donc c'est un énorme
problème pour l'union européenne qui est
donc décidé aujourd'hui de
de la création d'une zone humanitaire
même si cela donc encore prendre un
petit peu de temps une zones
humanitaires décentes at il dit sous la
décision des nations unies avec possible
le hcr qui pourrait être l'un des
responsables de ces zones humanitaires
évidemment rien est encore en place
parce que nous concerne le conseil
européen vient de se terminer
les décisions vont prendre du temps il y
à un conseil des ministres des affaires
européen des affaires étrangères
européens qui doit avoir lieu lundi
mardi à paris il y a également une
organisation tripartite entre l'union
africaine l'union méditerranéenne et
d'union européenne qui doit avoir lieu
dans les semaines à venir
tout ça va prendre beaucoup de temps ce
qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
y aura une politique migratoire sur les
flux d'immigration qui va se mettre en
place avec les différents acteurs au
niveau européen et c'est très important
car aujourd'hui en france et partout
ailleurs en europe il ya une vraie peur
celle d'une immigration massive de ces
pays d'où kéru connu une révolution et
nicolas sarkozy l'a répété
c'est un mouvement historique qui se
répétera et qui touchera tous les autres
pays du secteur du bassin méditerranéen
donc là on touche à un problème central
de la politique intérieure mais de la
politique surtout européennes les flux
migratoires ce sera quelque chose de
très important autre point clé aussi à
préciser celle des frappes aériennes
nicolas sarkozy et david cameron la
grande pour la grande bretagne avait
demandé des frappes ciblées
en cas d'utilisation d'armes chimiques
par exemple de la part du commandant
qu'à la fille du colonel kadhafi sur les
civils ils n'ont pas eu gain de cause
apparemment il faudra également demandé
évidemment la vie tout d'abord au
conseil national de transition
il faudra également demandé l'avis de la
ligue arabe c'est très important pour
l'instant pas de frappes aériennes
en tout cas pas d'action militaire et
angela merkel l'a précisé
elle ne veut pas de frappes aériennes à
ce stade alors en gala merkel justement
puisque ce conseil européen a pris
beaucoup de retard un retard
certainement dus aux divergences de
points de vues entre la france et la
grande-bretagne d'un côté et l'allemagne
de l'autre 6h conseil européen qui a
duré six heures c'est assez rare et
c'est vrai que le problème libyen en
euros peut être aussi la chandelle si on
peut dire ce qu'il fallait absolument
régler ce problème en interne autres les
chefs d'état
c'est vrai que depuis hier il y avait
une position entre la grande bretagne et
la france qui voulait ses frappes
aériennes ciblées ou en tout cas qui
voulait une action militaire l'allemagne
était totalement opposée alors que
d'habitude lors de ses conseils
européens
ayez un axe franco allemand très clair
qui se dessine aujourd'hui cet axe
franco allemand s'est on va dire pousser
vers un axe franco britannique angela
merkel n a tenu une conférence de presse
il ya quelques instants pour dire très
clairement qu'elle ne voulait pas de
frappes aériennes on sent qu'il n'y a
pas encore de consensus
valable entre tous les pays européens
car le texte
nicolas sarkozy l'a précisé n'est pas
encore clairement écrit il va falloir
encore sûrement travailler avec les
autres pays européens et notamment avec
angela merkel qui end pour l'instant est
sur une position un peu différente de
celle des français et des britanniques
alors michael pour terminer ce sommet
européen a eu lieu à l'initiative de
nicolas sarkozy à suivre un sommet
extraordinaire de la zone euro
toujours à l'initiative de nicolas
sarkozy en tant que président du g20
ces sommets est ce un moyen pour nicolas
sarkozy de redorer son blason
n'oublions pas qu'il est président du
g20 donc à ce titre évidemment c'est
normal qu'il soit en pointe sur les
questions internationales mais c'est
vrai que les sondages en ce moment en
france ne sont pas très bons pour
nicolas sarkozy alors une façon de
redorer son blason ou en tout cas de se
porter à l'offensive
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être vrai
c'est vrai qu'il a répété que la france
était à l'offensive et était la première
à demander cette réunion qu'on vient de
voir ce conseil extraordinaire européen
également cet après-midi en fin de
journée avec une conférence de presse
qui aura lieu très tard ce soir sur les
questions de l'euro c'est que ce sont
des problèmes qui concernent énormément
les français mais on sent bien qu'il ya
une stratégie de la part de nicolas
sarkozy d'être au dessus des problèmes
peut-être franco-français et de
s'intéresser aux problèmes du monde
comme étant le président du monde et
et peut-être là il faut y voir peut-être
aussi une stratégie politique mais c'est
vrai que la libye est un grand problème
mondial
donc on peut lui faire crédit en tout
cas sur ce point de s'intéresser d'être
très actif sur la question libyenne
merci beaucoup mais qu'elle nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur ce conseil
européen extraordinaire dans notre
édition de 19 heures présentée ce soir
par pierre henri gergonne très bonne
soirée sur public sénat